the only thing more frightening than my
own prom has to be Brian De Palma's 1976
horror film Carrie and part of the
reason I find it so terrifying is not
the blood and gore CC SpaceX chilling
performance or John Travolta's for that
matter but the way the tension is
written into the script so in this
episode I want to break down the prom
scene from Carrie and figure out how
screenwriter lawrence Cohen and director
Brian De Palma created one of the
tensest sequences in cinematic history
but before we get into the fun stuff we
have to know the difference between
tension and suspense because knowing
this difference will give us greater
insight into how De Palma and Cohen
constructed their tension think of
suspense is a state of mental
uncertainty will Hans Landa discover
Monsieur Lapidus Jewish neighbors
beneath the floorboard will Clarice
Starling realized the person she's
talking to is in fact Buffalo Bill
suspense usually involves an element of
danger where we're constantly asking
ourselves what will happen next
tension on the other hand is an element
of suspense which gauges how much we
care about the characters when the
characters we love are put in harm's way
such as a bucket of blood about to rain
down on your custom Maine dress on prom
night
we are concerned for them that's tension
whether it falls or not that suspense so
let's break down the prom sequence and
see how these two tools work in unison
taking place near the end of act 2 the
prom sequence can be broken into three
distinct segments each serving a
specific purpose over its 25-minute
runtime
segment one I've aptly named heaven and
it runs the longest of the three at
roughly 12 minutes
here we see Carrie normally a social
outcast fit in for the first time she
continues to fall deeper in love with
Tommy shares not only her first dance
but her first kiss Tommy who
begrudgingly asked Carrie out at the
behest of his girlfriend seems to
actually fall for her it's romantic cute
at times awkward but for Carrie it's the
happiest she's ever been and that's the
point of this segment
to set up a happy contrast to the
impending doom
of segment to purgatory unlike segment
one which is completely devoid of
suspense or tension segment two builds
in and it builds it unrelentingly until
it's bloody climax but in order to
understand how and why this tension
works we have to pause for a second and
take note of a few things that happen in
the first and second act one the mystery
behind carries telekinesis leading up to
prom carrie uses her telekinetic
abilities seven times five of the seven
occurring in the first 20 minutes then
sparingly as an uneasy reminder of her
power and this was a conscious decision
on De Palma's part as he notes in cinah
fantastique magazine in 1977 unlike the
novel I felt that telekinesis was
basically a device to trick and I wanted
to use it as an extension of her
emotions her feelings that were
completely translated into actions that
only erupted when she got terribly
excited terribly anxious or terribly sad
for De Palma and Cohen who was more
important that her power be an extension
of her humanity rather than a gimmick
additionally we never fully grasped the
extent of her power nor does Carrie in
fact she goes to library to research the
change that's happening to her body a
change that runs parallel with the
physical changes happening to her as
well the point here is that kiri has a
power but we don't know the extent of it
nor what Carrie would do if she was
truly pushed into a corner
second and most important leading up to
prom Coenen stills and the characters
empathetic qualities or qualities that
make us connect and relate to them these
qualities are given to four particular
characters so that when the suspense
kicks in so does the tension because we
will be connecting and caring about them
these four characters are Sue Snell miss
Collins Tommy and Carrie herself
sue is really the impetus for the film
she is the one who feeling guilty about
her treatment of Carrie asked her
boyfriend Tommy to take Carrie to the
prom
she additionally stands up to Carrie's
bully Chris and generally once Carrie to
fit in one could say the quality that
defines sue is compassion now there are
other qualities associated with these
characters but for the purposes of this
video I'm just going to go over the main
ones miss Collins is similar to sue she
sticks up for Carrie by reprimanding the
class Carrie why has feelings makes an
effort to connect with Carrie that's a
pretty girl and a skeptical of Sue and
Tommy's decision to take her to prom you
know I can make sure that you don't hurt
Carrie wide anymore
her quality is protection tommy is
interesting although he is initially
reluctant to ask out Carrie when he does
he makes every effort to be a gentleman
he makes her feel beautiful and even
encourages her to get out of her comfort
zone
his flirting even leads to a kiss which
in my opinion is genuine
although Tommy is a 1970s version of her
bro you can tell by his actions he has a
good heart
Tommy's quality would be chivalry and
finally we have Carrie many believe the
reason we connect with her is that we
feel sorry for her getting bullied
I disagree however that this is the main
reason as that is more an act of
sympathy rather than empathy just
because something bad happens to a
character doesn't mean we care about
them yes it's horrible that Carrie gets
picked on and yes some of us may relate
to getting bullied I'll be it likely not
to the extent she does her dreams of
wanting to fit in
live a normal teenage girl's life break
away from her domineering mother and
experienced teenage love I find far more
heartbreaking and ultimately connecting
than simply feeling sorry for her take
away those things and you get a less
rounded or flat character for a more
detailed distinction between sympathy
and empathy check out my other video on
empathy and horror films so now that we
care about the characters and armed with
the knowledge of carries mysterious
power we can quite literally set the
stage for segment 2 purgatory I call
this segment purgatory because it's the
gateway between the fairy tale prom
found in heaven and the hell that is
about to ensue in segment 3 purgatory
starts with bullies Billy and Chris
hiding under the stage getting ready for
the prank
this shows the seeds of suspension and
starts the process of tension this is
followed by a two minute and 13 second
long shot that gives us everything we
need to know to probably trigger this
tension we know the vote for prom king
and queen is being rigged when normal
slides the real ballots under the stage
and that a precarious bucket of pig's
blood hangs ominously over the stage
it's our minds that puts two and two
together will Carrie get dunked in blood
that's the suspense caring about whether
or not she gets dunked that's the
tension when Tommy and Carrie are
announced as prom king and queen that's
when things really start to amp up this
increasing tension is accentuated in
that we view it from five different
perspectives four of which are
characters we care about the editing
cuts between all of these vantage points
this was written into the script as
Cohen uses the scene headings to dictate
the pace of the tension su stage wings
peering out farther to get a good look
unseen at first by her there's a cord on
the edge of the frame Tommy and Carrie
dialling as they're led down the aisle
past a blur of smiling faces the
applause swelling the lights get
brighter the music gets louder beneath
the stage Chris listens to the footsteps
coming overhead grasping the cord Billie
is hooked up holding it very tightly sue
in the wings watching the action in the
corner of the frame the cord we glimpsed
earlier the same one which Chris
clutched beneath the stage jiggles and
sue notices it move she traces its path
with her eyes seeing that it goes up to
a bank of lights concealing a single
silver bucket every
this lead up from the slow motion music
and editing Cohen wrote into the script
and these elements combined with De
Palma's direction make for a truly tense
scene eventually releasing as soon as
Chris releases her hands from the rope
Carrie
now dripping in blood and ridiculed in
front of her entire school takes us into
the final segment of prom hell this is
our catharsis or the emotional tension
built in the previous segment releases
the characters we care about are either
incapacitated killed off quickly or
escaped in the nick of time from this
point on it is nothing but blood terror
and revenge it is here we see the full
contrast between segment 1 as well as
see the extent of Kerry's power and how
far she will ultimately take it
Kerri could have easily turned into an
emotionless revenge story but because
Cohen and De Palma took the time to
craft the characters the film still
stands as a horror classic the tension
is high the suspense is riveting and we
get a scene that goes down in cinema
history til next time keep on writing
[Music]
thanks everyone for watching make sure
to subscribe with notifications on so
you know as soon as one of my videos
drops and if you liked it please give it
a like
[Music]